codemasters the developer of dirt grid
and the f1 series of racing games has
hired developers from evolution studios
the team behind playstation 4 racing sim
driveclub writing on its blog the
publisher said codemasters will be
expanding its portfolio of studios to
include the highly respected and very
talented team from evolution studios on
my 22nd sony announced plans to close
evolution meaning that many of the
studio's work for space redundancy
according to codemasters the success of
F 1 2015 and dirt rally has repositioned
the company for growth which starts the
acquisition of talent from the formerly
PlayStation exclusive development studio
the expansion will not only CS gained a
wealth of racing expertise and skill but
it'll take code masses to the next level
as the world's largest racing focused
game company with phenomenal racing DNA
we hope the gamers out there excited to
see what we do next as are all the rest
of us at codys evolution studios
co-founder Mick Hawking has been
appointed vp of product development at
codemasters he'll be responsible for all
the company studios including the
addition of nav multi-platform evolution
team I am delighted to be joining
codemasters at such an exciting time in
the company's growth he said we have
shared a passion for racing a desire to
innovate and a determination to create
the best racing games and build the best
racing community in the market I'm very
much looking forward to working with so
many of the world's greatest racing
developers on new IP as well as existing
franchises including dirt grid Micro
Machines and the Formula One games in
his previous statement announcing the
closure of evolution sony said that the
restructure would allow it to focus on
other studios that already have exciting
new projects in development it continued
we believe will be in a stronger
position going forward and able to offer
the best possible content of the highest
quality for our consumers at the time
poorest in ski directory of driveclub
banked fans and Sony for their support
firstly a big thank you to all the fans
have supported us through evo storied
history we couldn't have helped achieve
what we did without you thank you to
Sony who helped Eva rise the top tier of
racing game teams in the world working
as a first-party team has been a
fantastic experience so are you excited
to see what this new team can build
together let us know in the comments
section below or find me on twitter at
arregle dave and for your gaming news
stay tuned to gamespot com
you